ببطانيه مغبره رميه لتغطيتها انتشل عدد من
الرجال مولوده جديده من تحت الركامه
وحملوها بعيدا عن حطام ابقى تحته والدتها
واخفت انفاسها الاخيره فمن رحم المعاناه
يولد الامل والده الطفل وفق مواقع التواصل
لقيت حتفها بعد ولادتها مباشره
ولاقت عائلتها المكونه من سبعه اشخاص
مصيرا مشابها
ناشطون اكدوا ان مقطع الفيديو يعود للسيده
سوريه مهجره من منطقه دير الزور اسمها
عفراء هذه الام هربت باطفالها من القصف
والمعارك والتمست رحمه جدران منزل واقع في
ناحيه جنديرس التابعه لمنطقه عفرين في حلب
غير ان هذه الجدران المتهالكه اصلا عجزت
عن الصمود في مواجهه الزلزال بقوه سبع
درجات فاصله سبعه على مقياس ريختر زلزال
اسفر عن مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وسط نقص
كبير في المشافي والمعدات الطبيه ففي
سوريا كل مصاب او ناجا من تحت الحطامى
مشروع ضحيه جديد